this man has a highly successful podcast
called an oral history of the office and
now
with full interviews from uh from that
pod
the office deep dive with brian
baumgartner
is available now on iheartradio and
wherever you get your podcast with new
episodes releasing
every tuesday featuring full-length
interviews with folks like steve carell
john krasinski and more from behind the
scenes of the hit tv show that you can
also see right here on peacock
our friend brian baumgartner back here
on the rich eisen show how you doing
brian
i'm great rich how are you i'm doing
well how's that golf game of yours
you know i've been struggling a little
bit rich but
i guess that's golf right that is the
beauty of golf
no seriously are you one of those that
won't say your handicap publicly because
you want to make sure you don't give
away candy you're not supposed to when
you're actually playing with people what
is that is are you one of those players
i'm not that smart
i'm not that smart i i a lot of people
they they want to keep that number up
because that maybe they play for
something now and then which i'm not
afraid to do
yes but i'm proud i'm in the single
digits but i've moved
my single digits i'm like an eight so
you're breaking what
so you're you're breaking 80 every time
out right now
i'm trying that's my goal is that i say
the first number to be a seven
okay he's usually not i'm usually like
81. what's the best track you've ever
played
brian that you're proud of my favorite
course yeah that you've ever played your
best
your favorite track uh i love shadow
creek in vegas
i just i love shadow creek in vegas
um i i played you know what the
augusta national and pine valley always
switch back and forth to be the top
course
i have not played augusta i have played
pine valley
but i was not as
good then as i am now and it rained when
i was there
so i didn't i wasn't able to fully
appreciate it the best
the best part about shadow creek is that
if anybody's fortunate enough to go play
it in las vegas it's just so you're on
the strip
you're in vegas it's totally vegas and
then you go behind the
the gates there and it's like you know
there's
uh indigenous creatures that are not
indigenous to
las vegas nevada it's insane it's like
you're in the carolinas yes exactly
you're in the carolinas and you see
then you see like i think they do and
i'm not just saying this i think they do
have like peacocks there like they
literally do you're like strolling
around there's birds that you're like
okay i i definitely am not seeing that
tonight at the wind
you know and it's it's it is and
that's my problem is i'm not focused
enough like i'm looking at the birds and
everything else and i should be locked
in on the on the golf and that's just
i am not good when it comes to that man
that's my problem
me too well it doesn't sound like it's
the reason we do something else i know
so let's talk about your pod
congratulations on on that just
as if this just in the office is
extremely popular
uh have you learned anything about the
show the hit show that you were on
uh and has definitely come to uh be so
good
for you in your life i mean and to you
and
with you did you learn anything through
this process that yeah i mean
it really it really was rich
started out as an exploration like
why is this show and and we were the top
show
a scripted show on nbc for most of the
time we were on the the latter two
thirds
but like why is this show exploded now
like why is it
way bigger now and in fact like based on
any metrics you can figure out like
the most watch show in television today
and we haven't filmed anything in eight
years and it was really about that
and there was a lot i mean people's
candidness with me their their time that
they get i sat down with most people for
two to three hours
and just and just went through it and
people at this point were willing to go
back through it
i think the biggest takeaway for me
because it's
been a question like why are the kids so
into it like why
are there 12 year olds coming up to me
and saying
all of these lines to me like how why is
this happening
and we thought legit when the show was
on
like this was something we talked about
because the ratings struggled early on
and we were like there was something
like there are 200
million americans who work in offices
okay
so if like ten percent of those or even
five percent of those like watch our
show we're going to be okay like we'll
be on the air for a while
and i think what we we truly weren't
thinking about
were the similarities between an
unreasonable boss
who makes his employees do unreasonable
things
sitting next to people you don't choose
to sit next to
for year after year is so similar to
an unreasonable teacher yeah uh making
you do unreasonable things
as students sitting next to the same
group of people year after year and the
similarities between
school and being stuck in school with
people and being stuck in that office
it really resonates with with young
people that's the biggest takeaway for
me well i mean especially since brian
baumgartner here on the rich eisen show
you know your character dwight obviously
the one that john krasinski played
as well steve carrill um and
and so much more ed helms when he was on
as well
it's just the childlike behavior i mean
the pranks that were played the
childlike behavior in an office setting
is similar also to school when you know
you're you're you're trying to maintain
a certain amount of decorum and you
don't want to and that makes it a little
bit more
you know uh i guess
divisive or something that you're
getting away with something
maybe that's what it is too because yes
laugh out loud
reverse it right yeah the show is
subversive
yeah and so i i think that makes it kind
of cool and
um yeah but it it i had i just had so
much fun
going back with people who you know i
mean
everybody's grown up you know had kid
moved away you know
john krasinski for example you know he
lives across the country now and
you know just being able to get back
together with
people that now you know we used to
spend 12 to 13 hours a day with and now
it's
usually a text here and there and um
during fantasy football season or
whatever but
it was so fun to go back and and talk
about that time
i've got brian baumgartner here on the
rich eisen show the office deep dive
with brian baumgartner podcast available
uh on i heart radio wherever you get
your podcast new episodes releasing
every tuesday
there's also an oral history of the
office that you can check that one out
as well
so when you say fantasy football i know
we've had this conversation before i
don't care because it's so fascinating
to me
who is in this office fantasy league
that you're still doing you said you
haven't shot anything in eight years
i think i think yeah i think we're like
it
year 18 this year
we still do it i mean and i told you
this when
when we started we had a
and you know we were shooting we were
trying to actually work make a
television show
our draft would last days
and we had a jealous door because it's
true
a yellow legal pad that
would get passed around the office as a
prop or whatever and when it was your
turn to draft
and maybe you were in the middle of a
scene so there was no clock
on our draft so it would literally last
days and if you got to
you know it was my pick and i'd gone
home for the day well we pick it up the
next morning or
um that's where we started we now
uh well especially this last year we get
together okay so we
we did it over zoom a lot of people did
this last year
yes uh during the pandemic but uh john
krasinski
is uh is in it i'm gonna miss people
there's twelve of us
uh actress john krasinski uh uh
rayne wilson's obviously uh myself
um and we've got writers directors
uh prop guy uh sound guy
i love
largely the same group you got a trophy
like that you you send to each other or
or or a punishment for finishing last is
that that that type of a league
that as well you know no we never did
that but now
i truly in this second just thought that
we should get a dundee
we should have it done a fantasy
football
dundee yes that we pass around i'm just
you just help me come up with this idea
i love it start that let's do it
that thing that yeah absolutely and um i
i would actually help chronicle that
damn thing you know because there's got
to be
some great smack talk that that goes on
so i know
uh ryan is a seahawk and krazynski's a
patriot right
he's a patriot fan yeah that is correct
and you're an atlanta falcon guy
um along with a little touch of the
packers but
the falcons uh you you like the drafting
of pits
or you thought maybe they should have
gone in the direction of
of finding the the next quarterback uh
while matt ryan is
is still there what'd you think of that
one brian ah i like the pick actually
i thought he was you know what do they
say best available player
i think he's super interesting and um
and you know i think maddie's maddie's
still got some
um you know i think he's got stuff still
left in him and uh
i i yeah i i like the pick actually well
i mean and he's definitely somebody that
i would choose in a fantasy draft that's
for damn sure
kyle pitts oh yeah i mean i would take
him in an absolute heartbeat
okay so you got that going for you and
the fact that he's uh
you're a georgia bulldog and he's a
florida gator that doesn't matter to you
because that does bother me quite a bit
okay i appreciate it it does bother me
quite a bit but i
what are you gonna do i i think he was
the best i think he was the best
available player and i think
he changes their it gives their offense
a lot of flexibility i mean yeah
okay i've got brian baumgartner here uh
on the rich eisen show okay
um i'd like to play celebrity true or
false with you here on the show where
there's some uh items that we have seen
on uh various wikipedias and things of
that nature that i would love to have
you
tell me you're true or false if you
don't mind brian okay okay here we go
here we are gonna have animation we'll
dress it up go for it please
hit the celebrity true
or false you can't handle the truth
[Music]
okay here we go first one brian
baumgartner true or false you along with
your multiple other castmates like say
jenna fisher angela kinsey bj novak in
particular
you're actually using your computers on
the set of the office to do various
things from surfing on myspace to paying
your actual bills in real life is that
true or false
that is true my my space
was the uh that was the social media of
choice
and we created we
i think i'm just supposed to say true or
false but i think so please think
we were supposed you know the ratings
were struck we were struggling early on
and we
to try to find fans created
uh myspace pages for our fictional
characters
so it wasn't brian baumgartner kevin
malone
had a myspace page that he blogged as
though he were kevin malone
working in a paper company called dunder
mifflin yeah that is true
so you're actually curating that or some
of the writers were helping you curate
that
no that was that was all me and and
jenna had one angel had one
eventually everyone was like okay this
is silly
uh and they kind of gave it up and and
came through i never actually broke
the fourth wall if you will and i have a
very interesting book
i think in my closet i'm looking at my
closet in my office right now okay
i have uh stacked up in the back about
five boxes because eventually when the
show took off
i started getting requests for
a picture signed picture will you send
me a picture and i was like well how can
i do that like that's
i mean i'm kevin malone so i i
i blogged i wrote and people keep asking
me for pictures
i don't know why you want a picture of
me sign but if
you send a signed picture of you
then i'll send you a signed picture of
me so i have boxes and boxes of people
who played the game
and sent a signed picture of themselves
to me and then
then i broke the fourth line you know i
set up a brian bomb guard near
city shot or whatever so at that point i
kind of gave it up but i have all of
these photos from people
um some incredibly fun um
yeah in boxes in my office so you
actually were spending time during
because nothing's more
boring sometimes than shooting at uh
anything on tv because of the number of
times that
you've got to wait around and to
actually work so you were paying bills
people were paying bills and with the
the connections people
people were paying bills well and i i
was an accountant right so i was like
well these look like accountant papers
right
right they look like bill so yes i would
pay i would pay bills yes
i would bring in bills next one brian
baumgartner uh
true or false um that uh you were once
upon a time
in uh the great city of pittsburgh and
somebody
uh bought you a bowl of chili for free
while you were sitting there is that
true that
right is through it as well i mean for
me
personally yes i i just i mean the
the art of pick up could not get any
better than that i was i was i was
traveling
i was traveling i was alone i was
sitting at a bar
and i had just finished food i'm a
bartender and i
i was just i was i don't know i was on
my phone or whatever and the bartender
went to
put down food in front of me and i just
looked up and i was like oh no i
already ate and he looked at me like a
50s movie and was like that's from the
girl at the end of the bar
and i looked down and it's full of chili
and waving at you like uh hey nice to
meet you oh yeah
i mean and i and i did go over i was
like
okay i have to give it to you like that
is that was it was very funny that is
next level brian you do have to you do
have to give the
the nod to such a thing as well uh did
that spark that's right did that spark
anything i have to follow up
no there was no spark no no there was no
spark
but i did well i mean she's the only
time that's ever happened and and
that story has been told a number of
times okay very good it got my attention
i appreciate you telling it one more
time uh last one for you brian you
attended the same high school as ed
helms
and you graduated year before is that
true you've known ed that long
that is true as well yeah we did plays
together
we did uh we did we did plays in high
school
um he's an incredible musician as some
of you may or may not know
um i i am not but yes back then i
pretended
i pretended to sing or whatever and yeah
our parents
uh very close friends still got together
over the years
um in the same group of people and we
we were yeah we were friends we lost
touch you know he moved to new york and
started working on the show called the
daily show and um
i was doing theater at the time and we
kind of blocked touch as
one does for a few years and and it was
you know i'd seen him on the daily show
and but yeah i was shooting a
scene so just imagine that think about
someone
that you went to high school with that
you know and you were really good
friends with hadn't seen a long time
now you're shooting a television show
for nbc
and literally looking it was the like
the little interviews we call them the
talking heads where we were talking to
the camera and i
was delivering one two camera it was
rolling and suddenly i
looked left and there's a high school
classmate of mine standing there
unbelievable i was like what in the what
is going on
what and then i stopped i said god or
whatever and was like ed what are you
not even thinking oh he's an actor and
maybe he's coming to work on the show
what are you doing here bro uh but yes
that is true that is amazing and you say
you're not a musician so then
you were not uh playing the drums
yourself on the office
brian i mean come on now i i learned
over time i did not play the drums
quick story about that but i think is
funny if you know the character of kevin
it is the most meta
joke from the writers that one could
imagine
they made me the lead singer drummer of
scrantonicity a police cover band
because now
some some of you musicians may
understand this better than i could
explain it
but the singing
during of police songs is
off of the beat from the drumming
right so their joke was their meta joke
was
for me to be the lead singer and
drummer of a police cover ban i would
have to be a musical savant
able to sing off of the beat that i'm
playing on the drums
that was that that was the meta joke
so then they made me do that for nine
years fantastic
uh last one celebrity true or false
brian baumgartner calling in to
reveal all of his personal conversations
with aaron rodgers that's going to
reveal exactly what's going on between
him and the packer is that true or false
brian uh oh yeah what do you want to
know
anything you want to know everything so
let me just ask this have you called
aaron rodgers to say what's going on
has that at least happened for you um
i mean i typically during the off season
i speak to him
on multiple occasions okay and
uh so but you haven't lifted the phone
and say what what's uh what's going on
man that hasn't happened
at all um you don't have to tell me
during the off season we we speak on on
a number of occasions and occasionally
play golf i mean look
rich yes it does this does this doesn't
take a brain surgery to figure the
situation out does it
it doesn't take a brain surgeon well i
mean it does feel
you go you go you go to the nfc
championship game
in 19 and what if ever
you included i'm sure i did i didn't
pull the tape
but everyone says they just didn't have
enough horses
against san francisco right san
francisco faster
deeper stronger better we need some wide
receivers we need to defend the player
we have blah blah blah
you know all your guys talking about
what they need
and when you then
have a number one drop pick or i mean
of course they have a number one job
when they have a first round draft pick
and you choose to trade up
to draft a quarterback which i don't
think was a position of need
at the time that might be wrong uh
and you don't communicate with your mvp
that this is something you're going to
do and explain why
it doesn't seem like it's like if they
brought in
a big balding guy to sit at the desk
across from me at the office
and i was like uh what are we uh
well guys what are we what are we doing
here
am i am i under contract still i mean i
i told everybody i wanted to finish my
career here at gender mifflin
right i said that's what i wanted to do
right
so right what are we doing
yeah i was saying just the other week
that you know uh
i've got three kids 12 10 and seven that
the number of times that
i will essentially tell them when they
do something and i'm not particularly
pleased about it and they don't like my
reaction i'm like what do you think
my reaction was going to be when you
behaved in the manner that led to my
reaction
that is you know that is similar to what
you are saying like what did you expect
the reaction to be so
yes i i don't i i and look this is this
is
this is this is from me i mean this is
this is not this is
like there was well there was probably
one person more shocked
but it was almost no one more shocked
than me
watching the draft in what year 20 20 20
years 2020 when it happened
um i mean it just doesn't it anyway
and then all the decisions that have
been made after that
to a person that had said i want to
retire a packer
um all all roads
lead to that not happening so
i don't know why anyone is surprised
about whatever is going on
well i don't know what's going on well i
hate to tell you i hate to tell you
there's another
podcast on the office uh interviewing
people
uh brian and um it is by somebody who's
apparently
uh very similar to you and um that's
just been announced so i hate to tell
you
um just call i heart radio and say why
didn't you get the call
beforehand i think that's what you
should do personally
there you go everybody hey thanks for
the call brian congrats on all of this
success
talking about this you have clearly
tapped in further to
a fan base that cannot get enough of
you and your storytelling and
congratulations on that let's uh let's
do this again soon thanks so much rich i
really appreciate it let's golf sometime
soon here too okay absolutely i would do
it um
i am free for such things now that the
draft is behind us and all that good
stuff
thanks for the call excellent all right
thanks you bet the
office deep dive with brian baumgartner
podcast available now again
all episodes drop on tuesday
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here